The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK.
Let's have a recap
of last lecture.
So what we're doing is
use the Boltzmann equation
under relaxation
time approximation.
So that's the relaxation time.
And under this approximation, we
can write and also linearize--
so we keep the first order--
of the left-hand side of
the Boltzmann equation
and replace that f by f0.
That's essentially--
so the distortion
due to the transport.
And the f0 is the equilibrium.
So if f just equal f0,
there's no transport.
But say when we have
a gradient in f0
and in both real space and
velocity of momentum space,
we have the deviation
from the equilibrium.
So this is the
first-order solution
for the Boltzmann equation
under relaxation time
or approximation.
And using this, we say from
here you can look either
the heat flux, the momentum
flux, and the charge flux.
So you can do all
the flux and gather
the constituent relations.
We derive the Fourier law.
And in this case, we
took a phonon as example.
f0 is the distribution function.
But in this case,
the temperature
become space-dependent.
So t is the function of x.
And that we do not have
the momentum dependence,
so we took this out.
And you get f0--
f solution, and then from there
you calculate the heat flux.
And the flux is always--
whatever flux we had is f
itself times the velocity
in that direction.
And let's say here.
And then you sum up
of all the states
and per unit area so
normalize per volume.
So this is the flux itself.
And of course, if you want
to calculate momentum,
you put the momentum
per quantum state.
Or if you calculate
the heat, that's
the energy carried
per quantum state.
And next what do
we plan to do is
to calculate the charge
flux, the current.
So we're doing electrons.
And let's say as common in
Fourier law, so for a phonon
it's t is a function of x.
And when we did the
Newton shear stress law,
we say f0, we replace with the
displaced Boltzmann the Maxwell
distribution, because
the molecule has
a long zero average velocity u.
This is an average velocity--
v is the phase space velocity.
v itself recover from mass
infinite, plus infinite.
But u is a function
of the space only.
That's the average over
all the momentum space.
So this case, u is
a function of r.
So that's where we
took a derivative.
We again look at
the momentum flux.
We got the Newton
shear stress law.
And I might just comment,
for example, if you want,
look at this--
if t is a function of x, you
have both momentum transport
and also, say, the spatial
dependent due to temperature.
Temperature could also
drive the mass flow.
And this is, in fact, the
coupled heat mass transfer.
And we didn't go
into those details.
And if you want to derive--
I think one of
the homework, it's
actually doing the derived
thermal conductivity
for gas molecules.
And in that case,
you will actually
have to do, say, a mass
balance and heat balance.
And you will see more clearly
in the example we're treating.
And that's actually
for couple the charge
and the heat transfer when
we deal with the electrons.
So at the end of last lecture,
we discussed the electron
transport and we finally
show that the solution
will apply to electron is f0.
And then this gradient terms,
the complication for electron
is we not only have spatial
gradient due to the Fermi-Dirac
distribution here,
but also we have
the force applied to electron.
And because we're going to
have an electrostatic field,
the field will act a force
under electrostatic field.
So we combine all
this and we derive.
At the end, we have
three terms, df dx.
Ef Is the chemical potential.
And dc dx, which is the
electrostatic potential.
This is a I'll comment
where the reference--
and dt dx, where I have
temperature gradient.
So I have those three terms.
And the df dEk--
Ek is the kinetic energy.
So this is where I
made some comments.
So you have to understand what's
the chemical potential, what's
the electrostatic
potential, and what's
the electrochemical potential.
So we said the difference
between Ec and the Fermi level
is the electrochemical
potential.
So here, if this mu is relative
to whatever absolute reference,
so flat reference.
And this mu is made of the
electrochemical potential,
which determine how
many particles I have.
So how many particles I
have in the conduction band,
if you look at this, is Ek.
So this is the kinetic
energy relative to the bottom
of the conduction band--
that's Ek-- minus Ef.
So this Ef relative
to Ec is negative,
so that's the difference there--
Ek minus Ef.
So this is itself determine
the number of particles
in the conduction band.
So that's consistent with
the chemical potential is
related to number of particles.
And Ec relative to
the absolute level
is where of the potential
energy of the electron,
the bottom of the
electron, that's
where the potential energy is.
So mu, which is a
combination of Ef plus Ec,
relative to absolute, is the
electrochemical potential,
is the combined
chemical potential
with the electric potential.
So when I look at the driving
force, in fact, you can say Ef
and the two gradient,
electrostatic potential
gradient and chemical
potential gradients,
are equivalent positions.
They can both drive
the charge flow.
And then we have
temperature gradient.
So with this, you
can move to rest.
For example, I want to
calculate the charge flux.
I'm doing q.
For electron q is negative
E. For host, q is positive E.
So I'm just going to use q.
If I want to look at the x
direction, so I have way vx,
I have q, and I have f.
I have, say, 2, factor
of 2, count for the spin.
And I sum of kx, ky, kz.
So you can say, if I replace
q by mass per charge,
I get the mass flux.
It doesn't matter when I
deal with electron flow,
but it matters when I deal
with the mass diffusion.
So all those is
under the same idea.
Really difference is what's
the quantity we're interested
and what's the detail
of the f itself.
And starting from
here, your task
is the same as we did
for the Fourier law,
for Newton shear stress law.
You're going to convert this
summation into integration.
You choose your own
coordinate, whether you
want to work with energy, you
want work with the momentum.
If you recall, for Fourier law,
we work with the frequency.
For Newton shear stress law, we
actually work with vx, vy, vz.
And here, the best is still work
with the energy Ek in this case
because the f itself
depends on f0.
f0 has the Ek inside.
And that will be the
easiest way to deal with.
So I'm not going to go
through the intermediate step.
And I'm going to give
you the final result.
What I have is a coupled
term, L11 minus 1 over q,
and dEf dx, plus dEc
dx, plus L12 must dt dx.
So they current
flow is coupled to
electrochemical potential
gradient and temperature
gradient.
Ef plus Ec, again, is d mu.
So here is du mu dx minus q.
And sometimes it's also
written as the dq, mu over q.
Let's use a capital Phi dx.
And say this is called the
EMF, Electromotive Force.
It's combination of
electrostatic and chemical
potential gradient.
So here, because remember,
these are the energy units.
When I talk about
electrostatic potential,
I do actually Ec divide by
q, normalized by charge.
So there are different
units, and even
they all called
potential energy unit.
And the other is energy
divided by coulomb.
So I have those coefficient the
coupled transport, L11, L12--
let me give you, say,
expression for L11, L12.
And L11, after you do all
your math integration,
you say it's 1/3 q squared, 0
to infinite, and v squared tau,
and dEk and df0 dEk and dEk.
And if I have a parabolic
band, remember the energy Ek
is 1/2 mv squared over 2.
Or if I do, say,
in quantum term,
it's, say, 2m h bar squared k
because mv is the momentum h
bar k.
So you can convert this v into
Ek and do your integration.
So this is one coefficient.
And the other coefficient,
L12, is minus q divide by 3T,
0 to infinite, v squared tau,
and Ek minus Ef, df0 dEk dEk.
So if I know the
density of states--
oh, I should have
density of states, dEk.
So if you know the
density of states,
you know relaxation time, you
can calculate those transport
coefficient.
And if you recall, when we
talk about the electron energy
levels, Kronig-Penney
model, those
are the different
ways to calculate
the details of
the band structure
of different materials.
And from that, you can
get density of states.
And from density of states,
you dope the material.
So based on doping, you can
determine where is your Ef.
Ef can be adjusted by doping.
And this is a harder to
calculate tau, relaxation time.
We discussed, in fact, say,
there are really not good way--
not many calculation of the
relaxation time for electrons.
And because, let's say, once you
go to the scattering process,
it's always a higher order and
more difficult to deal with.
But say in general the
framework is there,
like you do density
function theory.
You can calculate
the band structure
of different materials and
calculate density of states,
Ef, all these other quantities.
And from there, you can
potentially also calculate
the scattering rate using
the perturbation method,
like Fermi golden rule.
So those are the
functional form we have.
And let's look a little
more into details
what the solution tells us.
So first, let's look at
a constant temperature,
T. There's no
temperature gradient.
And in the case of
constant temperature,
let's drop the first term--
the second term here.
Then the current flux is
related to electrochemical
potential gradient.
I further will distinguish
it, say, metal.
And in metal, the electron
density is very high.
So effectively there is no
change in the electron density.
And if you recall,
the difference
say between metal
and semiconductor,
when we discussed before,
this is the electron energy
momentum.
Let's say here is
the, say, electron
band structure, the energy
[INAUDIBLE] the relation.
In case of metal, my Fermi
level is deep into the band.
This is my Ef.
And most of this charge
below the Fermi level,
they don't have, because
they are more mobile.
They are failed states.
So only about the kt
near the Fermi level
are the charge that
actually moves.
So in this case, if I
look at the term Ef,
which is the chemical potential.
The number density of
the charge in the metal
doesn't change much.
So dEf dx can be dropped out.
It's really electrostatic
potential pretty much that
is driving the charge flow.
And if I look at the transport,
essentially this is Ohm's law.
Jk or the current
flux is proportional
to the electrochemical
potential gradient.
And L11 is the
electric conductivity.
So I have L11 is the
And in the case of metal,
this differentiation
is non-zero near
the Fermi level.
And other places, they
are all pretty much 0.
So I can approximate that
this integral with 1/3 tau f.
This is the relaxation
time at the Fermi level,
and density of states at the
Fermi level, E squared vf,
velocity at the Fermi level.
So this is the
electric conductivity.
And in which you
can further written
because let's say you can
relate density of states
to the electron number
density in the material.
So this is nE
squared, say, m tau f.
So the electric
conductivity in metal
is mainly the carrier
density doesn't change much.
It's the electrostatic
potential that's
driving the current flow.
Now if we look at
the semiconductor.
And in semiconductor, I have
both the carrier density
and the electrostatic
potential gradient.
They all could vary
in the semiconductor
when you make a P-N conjunction.
For example, there
is a large change
in the band edge of
the semiconductor.
So both term are changing.
And the current density
is often written
as rather than write
into just this term,
you're actually
sometimes split this out.
One is related to
density, E of dx.
That's related to
carrier density.
This one is related to
electrostatic potential.
So in semiconductor, the
famous equation people
saw is q and mu epsilon of x.
That's the electric field, which
is the gradient of negative,
just say, 1 over q dEc dx.
And plus a diffusion
term, dn dx, because dEf--
Ef determine the
carrier density.
There is a fixed relationship
between Ef and n.
So dEf dx is dn dx, and with
the diffusion coefficient a.
So here is diffusivity.
And here is the reason
it's written in metal,
we don't talk about the mu--
we talk about sigma.
In semiconductor,
this N changes a lot.
So you normalize the sigma.
This q and mu gives you
sigma, electric conductivity.
So here is sigma.
And this mu is the mobility.
So sigma equals qn mu.
And if you go back to here,
because sigma is ne squared m,
tau f.
So in general, mu is
related to m, n tau--
so no, no n--
e tau.
Say, E tau divided by m.
So measured mobility,
effectively you
say in this you have
the effective mass,
you have the relaxation time.
So it's a measure of
the relaxation time
and it will give you information
about the effective mass.
And now you can say, in
fact, both of those terms
have the same coefficient.
I'm just splitting them up.
So this is a diffusivity
and mobility are
related to each other.
And the relation between
diffusivity and mobility,
a, is kb t over e times mu.
And this is called
the Einstein relation.
It's a general
relationship, let's say,
between the mobility
and diffusivity.
Einstein didn't work on this.
What he really worked on
is the Brownian motion.
And in the case of
Brownian motion,
they are particle diffusivity.
And think about the
milk molecules in water.
The milk molecule diffusivity is
related to viscosity of fluids.
So this is a general--
in fact, I say the
generalization of this,
as I said before, Einstein
started this other direction--
linear response theory.
And this is a part
of, say, dissipation--
fluctuation dissipation theory.
General, very general.
So this is a--
diffusion is a
fluctuation process.
Mobility is a dissipation
coalition process.
So that's a fluctuation
dissipation theorem.
That's one example of
fluctuation dissipation
theorem.
And Einstein relation
between the mass diffusion
and the viscosity
is another example.
So there are many examples
of fluctuation dissipation--
very general.
So what the electrical engineer
do is solving this equation.
Here is called drift diffusion.
So this is the drift
the diffusion equation.
OK, so if you look at a
lot of, say-- in fact,
even nowadays, they see MOS.
MOS-- you all know, it's a metal
oxide field effect transistors.
And even with the gate
now shrank to tens--
I don't know exactly
how many tens--
20 or 30 nanometers,
the industry
is still using this equation.
And they just tweak
the parameters.
They tweak the mobility
parameter, diffuse field
parameters just to fit the
device characteristics.
And they know it's
not [INAUDIBLE]
because the electron mean
free path could be larger.
But it's building
in many softwares.
It's amazing that they can still
use it to design the circuits.
So that's the semiconductor
drift diffusion equation.
If you design solar sail,
this will be the equation
you're going to solve--
most of solar cells.
And so now let's look at the--
the first case we discuss
is the constant temperature.
And let's discuss when the
temperature is not constant,
it's a function of x.
So in this case,
I have a material.
I have a temperature gradient.
And in the x direction,
I have heat conduction.
And what happens-- first, if
I open circuit, Je equals 0.
So what do you have if
you have an open circuit
with J-- or not e-- q.
e is for electron.
q is a more general.
Sometimes I switch because
there are not enough symbols.
And when you deal with
heat, you like to use a q.
And you deal with the
charge, you like to use e,
but the e is negative,
so all this complication.
But open circuit-- if you
look at my flux equation here
and what I have is-- this is 0.
But I have two terms
on the right-hand side.
dt, dx is not 0.
So I will have d phi, dx--
non-zero-- that balance it.
So what I really
have, in this case,
I have my Seebeck
coefficient is defined
as the negative d phi, dx.
This is, essentially--
sometimes we use, say,
electric field-- the epsilon x.
But, say, I use epsilon
x before so I'm just
going d phi, dx and dt, dx.
And this one is the
Seebeck coefficient.
And it equals L12, L11.
And remember, L1-- my sigma.
So if I look at this, I
substitute the expression
for those coefficients.
If you say the difference
of the two-- v squared tau,
v squared tau, d
and d, df0, dEk.
The difference is
just Ek minus Ef.
And of course, in front,
there are small differences.
So what I have here is
I will have e over tau--
eT-- T is temperature.
E is the positive charge.
No sign problem-- v squared
tau and the Ek minus Ef.
df0, dEk, and density
of states Ek, dEk.
I write it because I want
to explain what it means.
v squared tau,
df0, dEk, dEk, dEk.
So you can say that this
is the Seebeck effect--
Seebeck coefficient.
And back was discovered in 1821.
That was about same time
electricity was studied.
So basically, when you
apply a temperature gradient
to material, you generate
electrochemical potential
gradient.
And what happens
now, if you look
at this is a temperature
gradient driver diffusion--
current.
So when I have
higher temperature,
the electrons diffuse faster.
They come to this side.
There are more on this side.
When there are more, the
chemical potential will change,
the electrostatic
potential will change.
They are readjusted to
resist the diffusion.
So this term is
resist diffusion.
This is diffusion--
driving force.
So at the end, you have
a left open circuit.
Left charge equals 0.
The current equals 0.
And you have voltage
develop across the material.
And so that's what a
phenomenological explanation.
Now if I connect this
to the band structure,
here is my conduction band.
And I just look at
the conduction band.
Here is where the
chemical potential level--
Fermi level-- is.
And Ek minus Ef--
so it's this difference.
I said this is--
Ef itself.
Ek is here.
So I have Ek minus Ef.
So is it an average energy.
You can say here,
this is Ek minus Ef.
So the rest is just
the-- here, you
can think about that each
electron at certain energy
level has a specific energy
dependent spectral contribution
to electric conductivity.
And I'm averaging that to
the differentiable electric
conductivity there.
So Seebeck coefficient
is the average
of the electron energy relative
to the chemical potential.
And this, also-- the
electron energy to chemical
potential is the heat.
So it's the average
energy per charge.
And you use thermocouple.
So next time, you can say you're
measuring a voltage rating out
of thermocouple,
fundamentally, is
average-- is actually the heat
per charge carried you measure.
And heat per charge
carried is also
the entropy per charge carried.
So the Seebeck coefficient is
really entropy of the charge.
And with that, you can
also appreciate why metal
has a low Seebeck coefficient.
So if I look at, say, metal--
I draw the Fermi
level of metal here.
And if the electron is
above the Fermi level,
they have positive heat.
If electron below the Fermi
level, they have negative heat.
But in metal, you are averaging
over all positive, negative.
They cancel each other.
So that's why metal has a
low Seebeck coefficient.
And in a semiconductor,
my hole is here.
My Ef is very close to the
conduction band or very close
to the valence band.
So normally, I want the
one type of carrier,
and they do not
cancel each other.
But in fact, in most
thermoelectric effect,
you actually don't put
very heavily into the band.
So your chemical wouldn't
get into the very
close to the bottom
conduction band, but above it.
And in that case, those
carriers in the bottom--
below that camera potential--
is actually harmful.
They do cancel.
So that's why in some of
those structure, people want--
rather than this kind of
parabolic [INAUDIBLE],,
but if you have those kind
of densities [INAUDIBLE]
sharp features,
you will be better.
That's the quantum size effect.
And we can go--
discuss more size effects
in the next chapter.
So this is the Seebeck effect.
And that's the associated
with the charge flow.
I have, also, the
heat carried by--
due to the drive
the charge flow.
And now, let's look at the
other, which is the heat
carried--
heat flow.
And what is the heat flow?
I already mentioned that the Ek
minus Ef is the heat carried.
And in fact, you could write
down the energy equals--
the first law
tells us the energy
equals the heat plus Efdn--
the chemical potential
times the change
in the number of particles.
That's the first law.
You can also add electrostatic.
So basically, the
energy in the material
is, say, n times the
energy per charge.
That's my E here.
So you can say, dQ per
charge is E minus Ef.
So it's really--
the heat is here.
Ek minus Ef is my heat.
So it's heat carried
per, say, quantum state.
So with that, I can
go to calculate,
what's the total amount of
heat when the current flows
in the material?
So JQ-- I think my book
uses the one is the Je.
The other is a small q.
But since I've been
keeping Jq as for charge,
so now I'm doing the capital Q.
So JQ, then, is 2
over v, kx, ky, kz.
And if you look at it here, when
we do the charge for quantum
state it's Q. And
here what I have is
the heat is Ek minus Ef and Vxf.
So again, I'm applying
my general expression,
general way how to
find out, what's
the flux for
different quantities?
And you go through the
conversion of the summation
into integration again,
and what you find out
is I have L21 minus d phi--
again, d phi, dx because
I already have f--
and plus L22 minus dt, dx.
So this is the current flux.
So I have a set
coupled expression--
J for the electrical is L11 d
phi, dx and then, 12 dt, dx.
And for the heat flow,
have 21, L22, dt, dx.
And in fact, that there is
a very fundamental relation
between those coefficients.
Any time you see
coupled expressions--
say the charge is
coupled with temperature.
That's a cross term.
If you write your cross term
into a general entropy--
so this is a generalized
thermodynamics--
the general thermodynamic, the
driving force for the flux--
the heat flux and any
other flux, charge flux--
is the entropy gradient there.
And for entropy, if you
recall, it's d, dx, 1 over T
and the q, right?
So it's T in the denominator.
So any of this-- if you write
into generalized entropy
as a driving force, then
this cross coefficients
are always equal.
And this is the fundamental,
say, Onsager relation.
So here, we have
Onsager relation.
And in this case, because
I'm not writing, say, L21--
say, dt, dx in terms of entropy.
If I use the entropy,
say they should equal.
But because I'm not
using the entropy,
so I have TL21
equals T times L12.
So any time-- this, like I
said, any couple the process,
you can always ask, where
is your Onsager relation?
Next time you go to seminar, a
guy talk about piezoelectric.
Piezoelectric is the
electrical and the pressure.
There got to be that coupling
coefficient from electrical,
to pressure, to force all
from force to electrical.
Their coefficients always
obey the Onsager relation.
And so that's the form.
And I'm not even going to
write down this expression.
It's all in the book.
And again, let's look
at the implication.
And if I first look at a
constant temperature case,
again, I flow current
through the material.
And this term drops out.
This term drops out.
But I can replace
d phi, dx by Jq,
then I have a relation
between the heat current
and the electric current.
So if you do that relation--
say you have, here,
you have the heat
current will be related to
the electric current L21, L11,
and Je--
Jq.
So this is the Peltier effect.
So when you fly--
flow a current through
a conductor associated
with current, there is
heat carried by the charge.
And this is reversible when you
change the current direction.
So this is the
Peltier coefficient--
coefficient.
And this is the-- the
effect itself is--
the effect itself actually
don't manifest just
in the same material.
And what happens
is that when you
put the two material together--
1 and material 2--
and you pass a current,
now, at the junction,
you do your energy balance
because the Peltier difference.
So there is more heat
flow out or more heat flow
in at the junction because
of this difference.
So you have cooling
or heating depend
on the current direction,
which is reversible as you
change your current direction.
And of course, if
you look at this,
because our Seebeck effect
is L12, L11 and L21 is TL12.
So I know this pi--
the Peltier
coefficient is actually
related to Seebeck just times
the absolute temperature.
So these two are
related to each other.
And this was-- say, this is
called the Kelvin relation.
But it's one, special example
of the general Onsager
relation I just said.
Kelvin is much
earlier than Onsager.
Onsager [INAUDIBLE] also for
the Onsager relation he develop.
So we have the example of the--
the Kelvin relation is an
example of the Onsager.
And I think I
mentioned this before.
Kelvin is, say, is Lord Kelvin.
And it's the same as Thompson.
If you check, he wrote over
500 papers in his lifetime
in the 1800s.
It's not easy even to type it.
OK, so that's the one case.
And second case, if I just
combine these two equation,
I can always eliminate the
electrochemical potential-- d
phi, dx.
d phi, dx, in turn, express Qp
flux in terms of current flux.
So what I have, if I
eliminate the d phi, dx,
what I have in general--
JQ equals pi Jq.
So that's the Peltier.
And then I have a the
next term is L11, L12--
L22 minus L12, L21 divided
by L11 and times dt,
dx here in the front-- dt, dx.
So what it means--
normally, you
would probably tend
to think L22 is your
thermal conductivity.
That's not the case
because you can say,
when I flew a current
through the material,
the heat flow is-- one term
is the Peltier heat flow,
and second term is a
temperature gradient-driven.
And so this temperature
gradient-driven
is not just L22.
It's this all combined together.
And so here, this term is the Ke
is electronic because here, I'm
modeling electrons.
The phonons, we
already did before.
Phonon, we did the thermal
conductivity expression.
Electronic thermal conductivity
is the Ke is this blob there.
It's a compilation of
three coefficients.
So if you-- in metal and
you can show that I say,
OK, Ke, again, say
all this roughly
give you 1/3cv squared tau.
And tau is the
energy reaction time.
And you can look at all those
and actually find the relation
because eventually,
what's connecting them
if you look at their
solution, f has a tau.
f itself has a tau, has a v.
At the end, you have
[INAUDIBLE] states.
So the difference between those
different coefficients-- just
whether it's
averaging the charge,
it's averaging in the energy.
So because of that, this Ke
and the thermal conductivity
and the electrical conductivity
are actually related.
If you recall in
the last lecture,
we mentioned for the
gas, it's the same.
The viscosity and thermal
conductivity are related.
So all of this is
because you come
from pretty much the same
equation, except that I'm
doing different averaging.
So what I have in
this is Ke sigma T.
And in particular, in metal,
this one is a constant,
and this is pi squared over
1/3 and KB over E squared.
And there is 2.45 10
to the minus eight
O watt Kelvin squared.
And this is the Lorenz number--
Lorenz.
And this is called the
Wiedeman-Franz law.
Wiedeman.
So in metal, the
electrical conductivity
divided by electronic
contribution
to thermal conductivity divided
by electric conductivity
divide normalize temperature
because specific heat
of electron is linear
proportional to temperature.
And that ratio gives
you a constant.
And if you check a lot of
material metal, in metal,
the dominant heat
carrier is electronics.
And phonons contribute probably
less than 10%, in general.
And you see that, indeed,
the electrical-- and this
is very close to this ratio.
So a simple, easy
way if you don't know
the thermoconductivity,
which is harder to measure,
to measure electrical
conductivity.
It can give you an estimation.
And of course, say, if
you do semiconductor,
that's a little bit different.
And if you do semiconductor,
you have to go back
to all this expression.
And turns out that this
Lorenz number depends
on carrier concentration.
Because your Ef is
changing, different doping
will change the Fermi level.
And hence, say, all
those coefficient
depends on Fermi level.
But the range so far--
this range so far
has not changed much.
And the theory I've
seen is probably
within factor of two difference.
But, say, it's a
[INAUDIBLE],, but it's
a theoretical possibility
that I have is
how one can design
a material so that
the electronic
thermoconductivity is 0,
but the electric
conductivity is not 0.
If you go to check
when this is 0,
but you don't want the
L11 0, you actually say,
functionally, it's possible.
So this is how you actually
achieve this in real materials
because that's very
important when you
deal with thermal electrics.
OK, so we have started from
the distribution function--
the division.
And we say, OK, if you write
all those coefficients,
you should be able to
show the fundamental--
this is, say, the coupled charge
to electrical and temperature
gradient and the heat
carried by the charge
to the electrochemical gradient
and temperature gradient.
This is the Onsager
type of relations.
And in many, many, say--
in fact, that there are
many very interesting
coupled process.
And I mentioned that
piezoelectric recently
say they are also
getting interested
in this so-called spin.
So electron spin
can also carry heat.
And the spin Seebeck
there, that's
become a so-called hot topic.
If you're interested,
you can check literature.
And magnetic, say,
we talk electron.
We talk phonon.
And there are also the
so-called magnons--
the magnetic-- collecting
motion of the waves
of the magnetic field.
So all those, say,
effects could be coupled.
And so this coupling probably
can lead some very interesting
technology or effects.
And so it's worth looking.
And if you do heat
and mass transfer,
again, those are coupled.
And in the heat
and mass transfer,
there is also
fundamental relation
between the heat transfer
coefficient-- the coupling
coefficient.
That's, again,
example-- manifestation
of the general Onsager relation.
OK, so I want the dig in
and get in with more detail
thermoelectric.
I look at my progress so far, I
found we're one lecture behind.
So what I'm doing is
trying to combine this
into the
thermoelectrics lecture.
I have 30 minutes.
You already have the
thermoelectric effect,
so it should be
not too difficult.
And what I want to tell you
is, where does ZT come from?
ZT-- so given what
you have learned,
I can write the energy balance.
And you can start
with differential
because the equation
I have given you
differentiable equations.
So if I think about
it in general,
when I have a conductor, I
take a differential element
I have both heat and the
charge flow in the material.
This is the x, x plus dx.
Here I have the JQ
at the x, and here I
have JQ at the x plus dx.
And when I look at
the energy balance
under an electric field,
I also have the change
in electrochemical potential.
So if I write my energy
balance for this problem,
so I have JQ at the x
minus JQ at the x plus
dx, that's the heat
carried by charge--
flow in minus flow out.
And I could have, also--
of course, you can
think about you can have
convection or that radiation.
I'm neglecting that.
But because I have electric
field, I cannot neglect that.
So my field is the current--
how much energy those
charge are losing
is how much electrochemical
potential gradient
that I lost in this section.
So this-- d phi--
gives me 0.
So that's my energy balance.
And if I-- sometimes I also
feel this is not necessary,
I can just write my--
here is my heat equation,
heat carried by charge.
But if I add the electrochemical
energy by charge together,
that's the total energy--
energy flux.
And that will give me
the same expressions.
So this is, say,
electrochemical heat.
And if you now substitute
what we have here--
eventually I wrote down a
different expression here.
Oops.
Did I raise it?
OK, so the question
I just written down--
so if this is a cross
section, A, so what I have is,
after I put it in, is dT--
A times d, dx.
This is the heat term.
The difference of
these two gives me
the Peltier times
the electric current
minus the electronic thermal
conductivity-- dt, dx.
And in fact, I say I should
erase this electronic.
I should just use
the total thermal
because I also have phonons.
I have the lattice
heat conduction.
So I combine them all
together-- dt, dx.
And then dx-- so this is in the
difference of the two over this
section dx--
plus I d phi, dx.
d phi equals 0.
But recall that I have to,
when I look at the d phi,
dx, I have to look at
the JQ and dt, dx term.
It's coupled.
When I have d ph, dx, I have to
go back and replace d phi, dx
in terms of JQ and dt, dx.
I have another term.
So now you put
all this together.
I'm not going through the math.
And what you have is K--
if I assume temperature--
say, thermal conductivity
is temperature independent,
that's the first term-- dt, dx--
kdx squared.
That's typically what I have
a heat conduction equation.
But I have an extra term.
That's what I want to show.
This is JQ Tdx, dt, and dt,
dx plus J squared over sigma
equals 0.
So this is the Joule
heating is I squared r.
This is the heat conduction--
normal heat conduction.
This term is a reversible.
There is an extra term
when I pass a current
through the same
material and depends
on the ratio of this current
and the relative temperature
gradient I can have along the
material heating and cooling.
And this is the Thompson term--
Thompson effect.
So that's Lord Kelvin,
and he discovered--
so Seebeck and Peltier were
all experimentally discovered.
And he tried to connect them.
And he said, there has
to be a third effect.
And he was honored for
this Thompson effect.
And this one is reversible
when you pass current
through the material.
And in fact, I say
the negative sign
because we have here is
more heat generation.
This is a cooling in the
current rotation there.
So the Thompson effect--
for this Thompson
effect, we can also
define Thompson coefficient.
So thermoelectric effect-- when
we talk thermoelectric effects,
there are actually
three effects.
So Thompson coefficient
is the cooling--
the local cooling
divided by Jq, dt, dx.
And this one is T ds, dt.
And this is Thompson
coefficient.
So in fact, say, all
thermoelectric coefficient--
Thomson coefficient,
here, Kelvin relation
between Peltier and
Seebeck coefficient,
you see, it's all related.
And there was a very interesting
guy in thermal electrics.
He's a Russian.
And he has a book on various
thermoelectric effects.
It's dependent on
how you arrange
your magnetic field, temperature
gradient, current flow--
there are probably
over 100 effects.
He has a table there.
Every time I go to
thermoelectric conference
we give a talk,
you'll see that table.
Some of this might
be interesting.
I really haven't looked
into all those details.
So the point is, see,
those coupled transport--
there are many variations.
So now, you can go
ahead go to solve--
this is a
differentiable equation.
If you, typically, your
Seebeck coefficient
will be, indeed,
temperature-dependent
so you can go to solve it.
And the most time,
this coefficient--
the Thompson effect-- is
actually is not very strong.
So you can approximately
neglect it.
So if you neglect it, now we
go to look at a simple device
analysis.
So the simple this
device is just a one leg.
Normally, you never
use one leg because you
have to put the leads there.
But when you think
about analysis,
let's say if I do a cooling--
if I pass a current through
and say the current--
let's say this is a
hole positive charge.
So the current flow
in this direction.
The hole flow this direction.
They carry energy from this
side to the other side.
The side cools down.
This side heats up.
So let's say this is
a hot, this is a cold.
You could create a Peltier.
That's the current application
of thermal electrics mostly is
using for cooling.
So if I neglect the
Thompson effect,
you go to solve this equation
based on the boundary
condition, Tc, Th, you can
find the temperature gradient,
temperature profile
in the material.
That's easy-- uniform heat
generation, heat conduction.
If you took a heat transfer
course, you can solve it.
But if not, but you
can still solve this.
It's a second-order, very
easy differential equation.
OK, so if you solve it, you will
find out the heat conduction.
At the cold surface,
you have conduction.
And this conduction is because
by cooling, you [INAUDIBLE]
temperature grid and Th and Tc.
So you have a reverse
heat flow due to heat
condition of the material.
So this heat condition
is kT Th minus Tc.
And this is coming back.
This is actually
not what you want.
But also, there is another term
because I have a Joule heating
term.
So this Joule heating--
again, you can prove,
I say, mathematically.
Joule heating is the uniform
distributing the lag.
If you solve that equation,
you find out one half go back.
The other half goes
the other direction.
So what you have
is 1/2 I squared--
I is the current.
R is the electroresistance.
So electroresistance
is 1 over sigma,
L over A. L is the length.
A is the cross section.
So this is a conduction due
to the established temporary
difference reverse flow
and due to the Joule heat,
conduct back at this interface.
So this will reverse
heat flow back.
And now if you make a cooler,
your electrical current
is flow this direction.
They carry a heat away
from this interface.
So the left cooling--
Q cooling is the Peltier
coefficient times current,
which Peltier is TS--
Thompson-- times current.
And then counterbalanced
by this reversed heat flow,
so let's say Kth.
K-- this is a conductance--
Kth Th minus Tc minus
1/2 I squared Re.
So this is the left
cooling you have.
What you really
want is this term.
But because of the material has
a finite thermal conductivity,
you want a 0.
That's good.
So you have heat reverse back.
You have Joule heating
in the material.
So you also don't like that.
You want the S large.
But you look at
this, the cooling--
Peltier cooling is linear
proportional to current.
Joule heating is I squared, so
there is an optimum current.
You can take that.
You find that I optimum, then
you take the gradient equal 0,
derivative equal 0.
Then the I optimum
is STc over Re.
So that's the optimum
current for the cooling.
And in this case, you'll
have the maximum cooling.
The maximum cooling--
I'm not going to write it down.
But when the maximum cooling is
0, you say, why do you do that?
When it's 0, you actually
create the largest delta
T. You don't cool anything, your
maximum delta T you can have.
So the maximum delta T--
I'm going to write it down.
So when you have also
Q cooling equals 0,
then you get your maximum
T hot minus T cold maximum.
And it turns out, this
is a quadratic equation.
So 1/2 ZTc squared.
And this Z is a famous ZT figure
of merit of the material where
Z including S
squared sigma over K.
And this is the figure of merit.
So the unit of this
is the inverse Kelvin.
You go the check.
And most of the time, it
appears as a product of Z
with the temperature.
So ZT is a long dimension.
Oh, OK.
This is a cooling.
But say, for cooling, I
don't necessarily want--
I want what's the
most efficient, right?
I also care about the
efficiency of cooling.
If I make a refrigerator
and that's a--
say, you don't coefficient
when you make a refrigerator.
You say, what do
you pay electricity,
and what do you gain in cooling?
That coefficient of performance.
So COP of cooling
is Q of cooling
and how much you pay
in your electric bill--
the power.
And the cooling I already have.
So what I have here, this one
you can say is a function of--
let me just--
I'm not going to copy it, but
you can put this one there.
But what's interesting is
what, in this case, what
is the electrical power
you have to put in?
Normally, you would
say, I squared R.
But that's not the case
for thermoelectrics.
You will have I square Re.
That's the resistance--
internal resistance.
But you also produce,
here, a Seebeck voltage.
It's S Th minus Tc, right?
So if you think about that, I'm
drawing is a positive Seebeck.
So the Seebeck voltage
is actually reversed
because you have more--
wait.
OK, so you have more
charge in this direction
then this direction.
So you have the--
what I want to say is
what should be this,
and sometimes I'm
getting confused, now.
So the sign should be--
because I'm only using
one type of material.
But if it's-- basically, I
need to put in more power.
The generated Seebeck voltage
resist my current flow.
So it's S Th minus
Tc times I. So
this is additional voltage
generally due to the current--
due to the
temperature difference
exist across a device.
OK, so I'm paying more to
overcome that temperature
difference.
So because of this, you can
see, when I'm optimizing my COP,
I have to take the derivative
of this with respect to current.
That's different than I
take a derivative of Q
with respect to current.
I have a different optimum
point for maximum efficiency
versus maximum cooling power.
Those are the operation
of the device.
OK, so you optimize this.
What do you find out?
If you maximize--
so this is like when
you operate your solar sail.
There is always an optimum point
because you don't want to run,
say, a solar sail--
later on, you'll learn--
this is the solar sail
typically current voltage.
And you want to say
this is your current--
this is a voltage.
This is a current.
And you want to optimize so that
the current times the voltage
is a maximum.
So those kind of
solid-state device,
there is always optimal loading.
You match the external
load to the internal load.
And when I do that, my optimum,
say, COP is Tc, Th minus Tc.
This is a Carnot factor.
If you have a Carnot
engine, that's what you get.
And then, 1 plus ZTm minus
the Th over Tc and square
root 1 plus ZTm minus 1--
oh, plus 1.
OK, so this is a long
idea factor here.
ZTm-- Tm is the
average of Th minus Tc.
So you can see, I always get
the product of Z times T.
That's where the ZT come from.
OK, here is a Carnot factor.
Here is a long idea
material factor.
And you want to improve
this material ZT,
so you increase those.
And you will see, this is
probably about 1/5 in many--
given ZT equals 1, that's
a lot of material--
Carnot material.
And that factor-- long
idea factor-- is 1/5.
So it depends, of course,
that depends on how
large is your Th minus Tc.
Just can't reach certain-- if
your Th over Tc is too large,
you use [INAUDIBLE].
You don't make a
refrigerator out of it.
You have maximum delta
T that you can achieve.
And you can also make
a power generator.
You reverse it, you'll
make a power generator.
And that's the-- again, if
you make a power generator,
you have a maximum,
say, efficiency.
And you need to
[INAUDIBLE] match it.
So in the case of
power generator,
your maximal efficiency
if you do it is--
this is, again, Carnot factor
if you operate the heat
engine between a Tc and Th.
And the imperfection
due to material
is 1ZTm minus 1, 1 plus
ZTm plus Tc over Th.
So this is everything why,
in the thermoelectrics,
that people will
say, what's your ZT?
Because you can't do much
with the Carnot factor.
Of course, you can always--
depend on heat
source, temperature
range-- you can improve this
one, higher temperature.
But it's the material,
also, how much you
can reach compared to Carnot.
And a few more comments--
first, if you do
thermoelectric material,
even if you get your best
thermoelectric material
at hand, you may not know it.
Because thermoelectric
material is a three parameter.
And this three parameter--
ZT-- if we look at ZT
electron in the numerator,
thermal conductivity is the
electronic thermal conductivity
plus phonon thermal
conductivity.
You have both.
K is Ke plus K phonon.
OK, so we said that in
thermoelectric, this Fermi
level can be
controlled by doping.
So it turns out, the
electric conductivity,
Seebeck coefficient
all depends on doping.
And if you dope the, say, very
high, you get in the metals.
Seebeck cancel each other.
We comment before, Seebeck
in metal is very low.
So Seebeck drop as you increase
your carrier concentration.
On the other hand, the
electric conductivity,
if you look at--
it's mobility times
carrier concentration
times charge.
So electric conductivity
will increase--
right sigma S. So you have
to optimize S square sigma.
You need to maximize.
And in fact, even
this maximum point
may not be the maximum
because your Ke depends
on carrier concentration.
So your Ke is normally small,
but this is Ke typical.
Phonon-- which is the quality
independent on carrier
concentration.
Carrier can scatter phonon.
Once you get a very high
carrier concentration,
Wiedeman-Franz law will say
it's proportional-- sigma K.
So that gives you
a typical ZT curve.
This is your ZT, and this
is-- your material is about 10
to the 19.
It could be 10 to the
17 to 10 to the 21.
This is the range.
So that's what I say--
this is 1 over centimeter cubic.
So even if you have
the best material,
may not know it because your
[INAUDIBLE] is not right,
so it just doesn't work.
So that's the difficulty
with thermoelectric.
You have to control.
You have to search.
You change one parameter,
the other parameter change.
Sometimes people-- this
is a control properties.
Say, one way, the other way.
They say, how you can be--
how you can fool the material,
how you can fool nature
to get better materials?
Second comment is this ZT--
Z seems like analysis is
temperature-independent,
but it's never
temperature-independent.
It's always
temperature-dependent.
So you go to look at your
temperature dependence.
This is temperature.
And Seebeck typically
increase with temperature.
Why is that?
So when I look at
the semiconductor,
I increase the temperature.
The Fermi level moved to
the center of the band.
So Ef actually
goes to the center.
I'm changing the average
energy of Ef and electron.
So that energy difference
becomes larger.
But they only increase
with a certain level,
then you start to drop.
Why is that?
That's because when I go
to very high temperature,
this is at the center.
There are equal
number electron holes.
The hole carry negative charge.
They cancel the positive charge.
So even though they
can't contribute
to electric conductivity both
because you have electron hole,
the energy that carries
is the opposite,
and they cancel each other.
So this is a bipolar.
And the bipolar is really bad.
So what happens, the electrical
is typically dropped and this--
they may not get at the same
point-- same temperature.
But those are different
signs of bipolar.
And also interesting-- it's bad
is because the thermal is also
shooting up at the bipolar.
That's because when bipolar
[INAUDIBLE],, the electron hole
diffuse from one
side to the other,
they actually carry
the bandgap energy.
So they carry a lot of heat, so
thermal conductivity is large.
So the ZT will peak at
a certain temperature.
This is ZT.
It will peak at
certain temperature.
So for different
applications, you
optimize and find the material
for different temperature
range.
So those are the challenges
to thermoelectrics.
OK, I'll stop here.